Well, welcome to IND 3320
Accelerating AI,
How Sun Life reduces latency and enhances
engagement.
My name is Salman Moghul. I'm a principal
consultant with, uh, AWS Professional
Services.
I'm joined here today
with three
wonderful leaders,
great colleagues from Sun Life who will share
their real world journey building
Gen AI applications,
solutions, architectures.
That keep users engaged while,
you know, during the complex workflows.
Quick introductions
from SunLife. We have Robert Chen. He's a
product owner for Gen AI Patterns.
To me, he's the OG who actually started the whole
thing and, uh, democratized Gen AI
at, uh, SunLife,
has built, uh, numerous Gen AI
technology patterns, uh, since early 2023.
Dennis, uh, Wolowic, he's the
director and domain enterprise architect for Contact
Center. He's building very innovative
multi-agent collaborative workflows within Amazon
Contact Center, which he'll go over today.
And then we have Walter Kurzat.
He's a senior principal engineer
and he's the brain.
Behind basically the
uh designing and operationalizing GEI
patterns at Sun Life
in a in a very tightly regulated
and secure environment
and interestingly enough uh this is the
same team who built a very uh recently
built an omni-channel Gen AI
solution called Code name Iris using um.
Amazon Connect and Bedrock,
uh, so the solution recently won some
CIO awards.
So the point is that if you wanted to come and
talk to,
uh, this team afterwards and how they
actually took this, uh, solution to production.
Please do so. We have a lot of contents. I know this
is the last
sort of last uh presentation before you can
leave, so
please stick around
and uh we have a lot of contents to cover.
All right, our agenda for today, I, I
will quickly explain the evolution of
Enterprise AI
and how this evolution has
caused some interesting and unique challenges.
Dennis will
walk us through,
uh, how him, uh, him, uh, Dennis
and his team are building
very innovative agentic concierge-like
system within Amazon Connect.
Uh, they are accelerating AI adoption within
Amazon Contact Center.
Rob will then show us, uh, their
contents assist, which is the
content generation and scoring platform within
Sun Life.
And finally, Walter will deep dive into
architectures and demos.
So let's talk about Enterprise AI and
how this evolution has caused some
interesting new challenges.
Uh, we have seen the event
of, or, or dawn of, uh, rack
systems, rack workflows.
They have been around. These are retrieval augment
generation systems.
Uh, these are single step,
uh, solutions that, uh,
you know, that what, what the reason why I say
single step because there's 11 round
trip to, uh, to your, uh, bedrock
or large language model to generate contents.
And there's a lot of human oversight involved.
We're now seeing, uh, deterministic agents
that are automating multiple steps
or multitask workflows,
and they're still very heavily being developed and
used in, um, SMBs and enterprises.
We're also seeing autonomous agent. These
are, uh, multi,
uh, multi-step agentic workflows with a large
va variety of tool sets. They
can truly mimic human reasoning
and capabilities, and, and, and now we're
starting to see.
Virtual worker agentic virtual workers
that can truly collaborate between uh
teams across your organization.
So while this,
you know, evolution has, has brought incredible,
incredible business values and, and it
has unlocked a lot of potential, this has also
caused a lot of interesting, you, uh,
interesting challenges that we'll talk about to deal
with. So
here's one like on the right hand side,
uh, on the left hand side you see a simple
Q&A, uh, chatbot. It
works perfectly well.
Your, uh, you get instant answers,
you know, users are typically very happy with these
instant responses, but on the,
on the right hand side you see
a more complex workflow.
This is the continences that Rob will go over.
And it's it's toward the right
hand side of the spectrum that we just saw in
the previous slide.
These are deterministic workflows moving toward
autonomy.
So analyzing, analyzing guidelines,
generating drafts,
and then
refining the output, these, these intelligent
steps take time,
sometimes 30, 60, longer.
So what is the problem here? It's, it's,
it's the response, right? So user
expects immediate response when they see
these spinners or 3 dot animation. They
think the system is not working, whereas
behind the scenes AI is working perfectly well, but
it just takes time.
Uh, to, to respond, so it's, it's
not a technical problem, it's more of a user, user
experience problem.
And undoubtedly in 2025
it has been the year for model context
protocol uh that
act as a catalyst or acted as a
catalyst that has sped up
the creation of these agentic systems.
It's often compared the USB-C port
for uh agentic AI systems
provides standardized way to connect to your tools
and data sources behind the scene,
um,
and. Suddenly
with the with the help of MCP building
these autonomous agents become very easy
for enterprises,
but there's always like a
catch, right? So the catch is that while
um you are able to build these things
very rapidly,
uh, you,
it takes time to execute uh energetic
workflow.
Uh, so
this really amplified that that
challenge that we just saw,
and as more and more enterprise adopt intelligent
agents through MCP, keeping
users engaged in your system
is, is extremely critical.
So how do we solve this challenge?
How do we keep users engaged during,
during these long running AI workflows?
Well, you probably have guessed and you have dealt with
it, uh, at some point, streaming
or, uh, real-time updates is the way to go.
And if you've been keeping up with these plethora
of, uh, reinvent announcement,
there was one just recently made around Amazon
API gateway now supporting streaming
natively.
Um, and you can also build
your webSocket servers
if you wanna go down that daring path, but
scaling those servers is challenging.
So for enterprises,
managed services that are secure and provide
necessary capabilities out of the box are super
critical, and that's why AppSync is
a better option.
And it offers three key capabilities
like flexible security through private
APIs,
uh, so your, your traffic never leaves your
VPC, it's always secure internal.
Uh, number 2 is the, uh,
request handling.
So it, it provides you with flexible
request handling so you could,
uh, you could stream these real-time updates to the front
end. You can also use resolvers,
um, for those who don't know what
AppSync is. We can talk later.
Uh, you can, you can change your request
and response resolvers using,
uh, uh, using, using these capabilities.
And then
third being the flexible evolution of
your API model.
So as you can imagine, as you're adding more
and more data points, uh, connections to your
back end, uh, your, you and
your consumer are consuming your APIs.
GraphQL has some capabilities built
in where,
uh, the changes in the back end doesn't really
impact your, your, your consumer.
So another key capability that enables
streaming is GraphQL subscription.
Uh, so
it, it happens over a managed web socket, so.
Uh, it provides, so AppSync
provides all these capabilities in a managed
way, in a more secure way.
Uh, talking a little bit more about security
for highly regulated customers like SunLife
Security, uh, is, is critical.
AppSync provides this API,
private API accessibility only from
your VPC
through private link.
So with controls at every level
you can, uh, use IM policies.
You can use endpoint policies
and, you know, security groups and whatnot,
so. Uh,
that, that's what SunLife uses behind the
scene. Another key capability
of AppSync is resource access
management sharing or RAM.
So you can share APIs across multiple
accounts in a highly regulated environment
where you have multiple accounts to deal with.
Typically you are only allowed. To get into a cloud
through a foundational or a network account
so you can share your workload APIs
into this foundational account and then
access it through
um through through that through that VPC
endpoint and Walter will dive
deeper into this way
deep uh in in in his section.
All right, so
Couple of patterns,
uh, so for simple Q&A bot, AppSync, uh,
calls
Bedrock,
uh, using its built-in capability
like these are data sources.
So there's a Bedrock data source you could bring your
context, your prompt,
called AppSync, and it will work, right? So
this, this is for simplistic workflows, works
quite well,
but for more
complex workflows that require
a longer time to execute, you need a different pattern, and
this is the async pattern for AppSync
where. Uh, which we talked about, this is
applicable to the right hand side of the spectrum
for the AI,
uh, longer running workflows, so user
makes a request,
absence mutation or query
to, you know, uh, start the
back end workflow
at the same time application subscribe.
So ASync invokes the lambda function which
orchestrates between your MCP server,
between Bedrock,
and you know, MCP server provides your
standard set of guides, uh, tools,
APIs, and databases to your, to your, to your MCP
and to your orchestrator
and, and then.
It starts streaming like as you're
going through as your AI orchestrator is going
through those multi-step process you can now
start streaming that data back to your
to your front end or to your consumer of the
API so
that
32nd
turns into a more engaging,
transparent, and explainable experience.
Uh, so this is
this pattern is applicable to any long running workflows
and, um,
and, and this is AI orchestration through
UX. Sunlife
also
leveraged multi-agent orchestration in their contact center
so that they remove dial tones
like press 1 for this, press 2 for this with
a very smart concierge system
that understands user utterances better than
your traditional built-in
uh NLP intent.
Uh, well, uh, Dennis will talk about this in
a second, and the concierge routes these
requests to a specialized subagent.
Uh, it can be an authentication agent to verify
your, or to, to authenticate your users.
It can be an IT support, uh, agent
that can handle your password resets
requests, and it can be any specialized subs,
uh, sets of sub agents that can handle
claims, you know, your, your benefits
type of, uh, requests.
So the key is to keeping this response time in.
Check when building these multiple agents
and uh what you're seeing here is
the example of agentic virtual
worker. These are multi-agent coord uh
this is multi-agent coordination delivering
complete self-service.
um, so to, to recap,
MCP enable agentic workflows.
AppSync accelerated AI through
real-time streaming,
uh, contact Center or
Amazon Connect accelerated through voice
and conversational concierge system.
Sun Life uses both,
so better UX.
Uh, faster, uh, you know, faster
AI engaged user and to dive
deeper into
the self-service contact use case, I'm
gonna invite Dennis Wolovi to the stage.
Uh Hit
the hit the green button.
All right, good afternoon. My name is Dennis Volovic,
and I'm a domain enterprise architect for
contact centers at Sun Life.
It's been a good reinvent so far. I'm
trying to catch up on all the announcements. I'm,
I'm looking forward to getting back and experimenting
with the 29 new features
announced for Amazon Connect.
Before I get started,
for those that may not be familiar with Sun Life,
we're an international financial services
organization, and our purpose is to help clients
achieve lifetime financial security
and live healthier lives.
Picture this.
You call customer service and within
seconds you're having a real conversation.
No menus, no press 1 for this, press
2 for that,
no repeating your account number 3 times,
just natural dialogue
that actually solves your problems.
It sounds too good to be true.
I'll show you how you can transform from menus
to a conversational IVR and
create concierge-like experiences
that move beyond keywords
to natural dialogue that understands
context, intent, and nuance.
From there
we'll get to digital assistance that will empower
your customers to resolve issues
independently through AI guided interactions.
And with conversational digital assistants
you can start to balance the friction typically
faced with tasks like authentication.
Contact centers are where AI can really
shine and transform IVR experiences.
The question is,
where do you start?
We've been, we've been working with Amazon
Connect now for several years,
and as we're moving through the journey
from touch tone to deterministic agents,
we're testing and learning thoughtfully
and responsibly
to ensure we focus on the right outcomes
and experiences for our customers.
The solution options I'll share helped us
improve service quality
while progressively enhancing the customer
experience on the IVR.
We'll start by talking about Amazon Connect
and Amazon Lex.
This is how you enable your IVR
for speech recognition and natural language
understanding. Then I'll introduce
services like Bedrock and EKS
that will augment the Connect experience
with larger language models
and model context protocol.
Which will give us more contextual
awareness,
multi-turn memory, and dynamic dialogues.
You'll come to see that there is a path
to deterministic agents, and along
the way there's value
that can be delivered for your customers.
All right, we'll start by covering a voice
powered
experience. Now this is a very nice alternative.
Your customers will be able to appreciate
expressing themselves verbally.
The solution uses Amazon Lex.
Uh, I know there were a lot of announcements
around Connect AI agents,
uh, but Lex
does remain the scaffolding that sits
between Connect and those AI
agents, so it's still an important concept to
try and understand,
and it's also a key enabler for Nova
Sonic. For
those of you that are unfamiliar with Amazon Connect,
that's AWS's customer service
platform, and Amazon Lex
is a builder for conversational interfaces.
Now what is a a Lex bot?
A bot is made up of intent. So these
are the actions that your customer wants
to take, uh, for example, uh,
asking about their claim status or what
their coverage amount is,
and utterances are the way that
your customers will express that question,
uh, what am I covered for?
So then how does Lex respond?
Um, Lex could respond
directly from the intent. So for answers that
never change, you can put those
right in your intent and Lex will respond.
It can also respond with a slot. So a slot
is Lex's way,
Lex's way of collecting more
information. So in that coverage example I
shared, uh, Lex might
present a slot and say, did you mean
medical coverage or dental coverage?
And finally, if you wanted to do some customization,
you can introduce a lambda.
And the lambda will let you do things
like attach to APIs, so this
will give you an opportunity to create
more personalized responses.
So again, going back to that dental coverage
example,
you'll want to personalize that response so that your
customer
knows exactly how much coverage they have
before they go and visit the dentist.
And one last point about the lambda is you can only
have one per elect spot.
Now let's turn our attention to Amazon Connect.
Um, Amazon Connect is where you
build the IVR experience and you can
kind of for those that haven't seen it, there's a
contact flow designer,
it's like a canvas you drop blocks on
there, you connect arrows, and that essentially
becomes
the journey that your customers have on
the IVR
and if we walk through the flow here that
you're seeing.
The way we manage the journey in
this architecture is through
Connect session attributes,
contact attributes, and, and when Lex
returns something, we use those session attributes
and together we use the
results of that to navigate the user
across the IVR
and you can see what's happening here. I've got 3
Lex bots so when a customer calls
in, you may want to present the menu
bot so that your customer can express
their reason for calling
and then as a result of that,
um, as a result of calling the menu
bot. It may be that your
customer wants to know what their coverage amount is,
so that could then
lead us to
showing the self-service bot and resolving
that inquiry.
Another valid outcome from a menu bot could
be that,
you know what, we're gonna have to put them into a queue so
that they can talk to an agent.
And then once they're in the queue waiting, we
may want to surface the authentication bot
and try to collect some more information from them
while they're sitting in the queue.
Now, You've got
lots of options here. You could collapse
all the Lexbots into one.
These really do become
architecture decisions
for you on how you want to develop that
customer experience.
Again, this solution has nice benefits.
It does eliminate the menu frustration.
It introduces natural language understanding,
and there is a structured
nature to Lex, so
you have very clear outcomes that that
your customers will get.
And with that solution it does deliver
value, but it does leave some challenges when you
wanna get to a more conversational
experience. There's been recent advances
in Gen AI that come with some compelling
solution options, and we'll get into those.
One of the things is as you scale those
highly configured experiences that you've built in
Lex, it's really nice to be able to augment
Lex with some large language models
and prompts.
Uh, in the previous diagram you saw
the integration, how there was a Lex, the lambda, and
then all your API calls
that feels very tied to
your Lex implementation
and very use case specific.
Salman spoke earlier about what's changed, and
he mentioned model context protocol. So
now those large language models that we've augmented
Lex with, suddenly we can use that
to discover tools on an MCP server.
And then the last challenge is more around user
experience and how do you manage the state
that's a lot easier to solve with larger
language models. The orchestration
frameworks like Lang chain and strands,
they've got hooks to be able to implement session
management and conversation
history a lot easier.
So I'll walk you through the solution architecture
and I'll share how we can level up the previous
design and get it to be more conversational.
So in this architecture,
Lex is still the gateway.
That when we when we spoke about
Lex in the previous architecture I talked
about how it's designed and how there's intense
and how there's utterances
and the idea is that when the customer
says something
Lex tries to match it to an intent and then
respond.
What I didn't talk about is
what happens if Lex
doesn't understand.
So there's another intent there called a
fallback intent, and that's essentially
Lex's catch-all
and allows you to create
responses such as I'm sorry, I didn't understand that.
Could you please rephrase your question?
Now why do I mention that?
The reason is is that the Lexbot
in this architecture has no intents.
All we have is the fallback intent.
So what's happening is that when the customer is
talking, it's going through Lex,
it's falling back, and it's going right
to the lambda, and that's where the next big
change comes in this, uh, in, in this,
uh, approach.
We use the
Standard MCP client SDK
and effectively we turn our lambda
into an MCP client that is
capable of calling an MCP
server hosted in EKS.
So when the process starts, the lambda will
do a fetch. It'll do a resources call on
the MCP server,
and it will pull back the configuration elements
it needs. It'll pull back the prompt
that it needs to drive the orchestration.
You'll also see in the diagram that I have bedrock
that's where we get our large language models
and when.
With the prompt that we just pulled,
we can suddenly
pass that over to the large language model
and the larger language model can then discover the
tools that it needs and then start orchestrating
the authentication flow.
Another thing on this that's new is there's a
Dynamo DB and we use that
for managing the session
and conversation history. We
could have just as easily used S3.
And
something that's not
reflected in here is that uh laying chain and
land graft, that's our orchestration framework,
and as a result, uh,
the persistence layer is implemented using
uh checkpointers that are provided with that.
Now let's look at the MCP server.
When we first started
doing this, the agent core wasn't
available
for us to use at the time,
and
one of the things we were thinking for expediency
was let's try to convert a lambda into
an MCP server.
But due to the stateless nature
of lambdas and the fact that they die off
quickly,
um, we thought not because MCP
protocols
operate asynchronously and
they are stateful.
And if we were to go to use a lambda, we
would have to build our own persistence layer
again in Dynamo DB or S3
so that we could rewrite those session IDs.
So our choice was to containerize
because that gives us that permanent
long running
mechanism. And
the other thing is, is that with the MCP
protocol
using session stickiness, it all kind of works
better that way for us.
Another thing about the MCP server, we
use fast MCP and multi-threading
to scale the MCP server container,
and then EKS takes care of horizontal
scaling when our workloads
increase. So
another. Either
in the MCP server you'll see that
we've got a couple of servers. We've got one
for authentication, so that's
we keep our prompts up there and then we
have several tools like a user ID tool
so that we can do a validation of the user
ID and an OTP tool so that
we can send a one-time passcode to somebody's
phone and then
uh validate that.
We also have a knowledge base uh
MCP server as well.
So let's talk about how this flow
is being orchestrated.
Before diving into the prompt engineering,
let's talk about what makes a deterministic
agent
with our authentication scenario, we
need the same
predictable output.
For given input
every single time, we can't have the LLM
decide a user ID is
good one day and then not
another,
or worse, let someone bypass it altogether.
So the agent must operate on a set of
predefined rules and make large
language model outputs more deterministic
by lowering the temperature.
Structured JSON outputs and leveraging
MCP tools for standard responses.
I mentioned earlier about creating a
concierge experience
and to do this we make use of prompts to
deliver a multi-agent orchestration.
The concierge is also deterministic.
It needs to properly
understand customer intent and know when to
route to a human
or hand off to another agent,
and the concierge prompt has its own persona
definition. It's got its own instructions
and confidence logic. It needs to know
when to route or ask clarifying
questions. So there's also retry logic.
Once the concierge has done the job of understanding
the intent, it may determine that
to fulfill it, it needs to call
an authentication service,
and here we do the multi-agent orchestration
and
introduce the authentication agent,
and this too has its own persona definition.
It has its own step by step deterministic
workflows.
We've all been through authentication. There's
a there's a clear sequence of steps. You've got
to resolve an IED and then.
Get on to the next factor like OTP
so we have to make sure that
the flow we create with the prompt is very
um step by step and deterministic
and of course there's the tool discovery.
Another neat thing about the authentication
agent, it doesn't operate in a dual
mode, and the first mode is the
agent decides the next step.
And then in the other mode, it's when Lex
collects input
via the slots that I mentioned in the
in the previous slide.
And
because we have a structured
JSON output,
that's what enables the seamless switching
between the two modes.
So when you augment the Kinect experience with
large language models and MCP servers, the
options with prompt engineering open many
possibilities.
And you can take this in endless directions.
I hope that you saw that there is
a path from touch tone to
deterministic agents, and
along the way there's a lot of value to be had.
Uh, before I transition to the
next speaker, I just wanna thank you
for joining, and I hope I've
given you some ideas on how you can accelerate,
accelerate AI
and transform your own, uh, IVR
experiences in your contact centers.
Um, I'll transition now to Rob
and he'll talk about content assist
and
sorry I.
He'll talk about content assist and
another creative use case for MCP.
Thank you. All
right. All
right, thanks, Dennis.
Never would have thought I'd be up on stage talking
about content at reinvent, but
content seems to be everywhere.
Um, social media,
email blasts, you know, everybody has their Instagram,
their TikTok,
their Facebook content coming in.
Problem with content is it's difficult to
create. Everybody hates doing documentation
even, but creating content is really tough,
and that's where the whole concept of
could we make it easier with Gen AI.
And that's exactly where we're going in terms of
how can we make things easier for
different use cases for content
as we start moving forward,
um, as Salmon mentioned, I'm Rob
Chin, product owner of GEI
Patterns,
and
started a journey with Salmon and Jenny I probably
around
2023,
and back then that's when there was
no AWS GEI blogs to learn
from. There wasn't any GEI services
and now it's probably pretty hard to find a session
that doesn't have any GEI in there
or Bedrock.
I remember in 2023 when Bedrock
started getting released,
a Google search just said that Bedrock was
where the Flintstones, the Flintstones were from,
but now we have Cloud, so you can ask Claude if you don't
know the Flintstones
who lives in the town of Bedrock, you'll get some interesting answers.
But um so let's jump into content
assist. So Continent
just started because GEI is great
at generating content.
So could we design a solution
that could leverage large language models
to help us
create, score,
and even rewrite
content as we move forward? And do
we have to limit ourselves? Large language models
really don't know what kind of content they're creating,
so we could do it for marketing, custom
summaries,
documentation,
even res you know, responses to RFPs.
You could definitely do if you just kind of guide it.
And that was where consciousness went.
Our solutions powered by Amazon Bedrock,
one of our preferred models and probably a lot of folks
in this room, um, cloud Anthropic
is one of the big models for creating content.
And the intent of the solution is really to
generate high quality content through
precise prompting,
and precise prompting.
The power of the prompt,
everything comes around the quality of the prompt
to generate,
quality output, and we'll be talking about that
a little bit later on.
And
Prompting in terms of content
who knows content the most than the subject
matter experts. So as we go through
here you'll start seeing that
creating content is really a partnership between the
technology team
and the business teams because I
know very little about content, but if we can provide
the foundation like content assist
to, you know, move this, um,
content creation forward, that's where we wanna
go. For today's demo,
I always wanted my own mock
company, so I created Perfect Frame Studios.
It's a company that specialize in creating
premium cat videos which everybody loves,
so we'll be using
Perfect Frame Studios as we move forward.
What you're seeing here is a preview we'll do the demo
later. It's a preview of
content that was created for Instagram for
Perfect Frame Videos and we'll start going
through. So
Consciousness is definitely wasn't developed overnight.
It was a very iterative process.
Started back in 2024 with
a few curious users, and the thing I found
about Gen AI curiosity is really what
drives,
um, moving forward with ideas.
So we had folks that were using
one line prompts, create an Instagram post for
XYZ Perfect Frame Studios,
did really good.
They're happy with the results, but over time,
The content looked very generic. It didn't have that
brand tone, that brand voice that everybody was
used to in creating content,
and then they, we started working together, the IT
team, professional services from Amazon,
we started creating prompt templates that we could hand
to the business so they could start pulling
in those brand guidelines and brand voice
that they knew
they were experts in, and we started creating
these complex, more precise prompts
that was really generating amazing
content, so amazing that we started
getting a lot of use cases coming in.
Business groups were filling in these templates, creating
these amazing prompts, so we started amassing
a lot of prompts that were being shared
that people were using and putting into an internal
tool that we had similar to a chat
GPT
where you would put the prompt in, put your content, and
it would generate it connected to Bedrock.
The key to getting good quality
content is
be very clear and descriptive
in your prompts, and we'll cover some of this
uh prompting styles as we move forward.
But as we started getting more and more of these prompts,
we created a UX wrapper around it so
that if you're a marketing person wanting
to create an Instagram post,
you would go in, select the
categories that you're wanting to.
It would pull the predefined prompt from the back
end and create the content.
Later on,
We thought about where else could we.
Introducing from a front end perspective, we
chose a web UI to start with,
but you could easily extend this out into
other channels whether it's Slack, Microsoft
Teams, or even a Microsoft, um, add-in.
The key, I think with any of these G AI solutions
is build your solution as modular
as possible
because you don't know where the next, uh,
technology platform is gonna be.
You know, we started small doing things
in our, our tool sunlight fast, but
then we took the prompt,
dropped it into a lambda,
dropped it into
a UX, so everything was very modular,
nothing was lost.
So I talked about
precise prompting and you're probably wondering what is this
magical prompt that we use to get this quality
output so I'm just gonna walk you through a little bit in
terms of.
Things that we um considered
so you'll see the brand guidelines we have it
captured within an XML structure.
Using cloud, um, the model,
the XML structure really keeps things
organized so that when you start referring to these
areas in your prompt,
it keeps cloud very focused.
So if you can get things structured
in the XML format in this particular
case, brand guidelines,
we want our marketing post to be professional and
caring, plain language.
We can talk about the brand examples,
good examples, bad examples, very
key bad example if
you have a cat with an attitude problem, no worries,
we can handle difficult talent,
not exactly the best example, but
maybe your cats need some extra time to warm up
and that's perfectly normal.
So these examples really help guide
the models in creating your
content. Other guidelines you
can bring in and as you can see as you start looking
through this content we talked about prompting
being the new development language you'll notice
that everything in here is really business
driven from the content experts so
you're starting to see a shift from
technical development more into the business side
of things so the business is driving a
lot of the content generation logic now
and we provide the foundation and content assist
to enable them.
In this case you can include call to actions,
anything that in this case a marketing team would want
to drive through very iterative
if you're not getting the right output, look back at
your prompt, add more details.
In terms of, you know, the output format
for this particular one, you'll see I ask it for
the actual post,
but the other one that I ask for is a reasoning, and the reasoning
is very key because
as these models generate your content
they're using your guidelines.
But when you're doing the human in the loop review to
understand why did it write a
marketing post in a particular way,
the LLM will actually go through and say I
wrote it because you told me,
and a lot of the times it'll actually be spot
on. Because your guidelines weren't
specific enough and then you can go back
in and start tuning it
so be specific
and then lastly
telling it step by step exactly what you want.
The LLM to do as you go through and
if it's starting to, you know, drift and not
follow exactly what you um are
expecting
just start adding on to your instructions
so you start pulling all of these sections into
your overall prompt
and we're having complex prompts now that are like
5 to 10 pages in length.
Which is giving really good
results, but it does create challenges.
Complex prompts take longer to run, which
is expected to get quality. It
takes time.
So when we had these complex prompts
being run, they could take up to a minute in time.
Users are impatient. Nobody likes to wait. They
start flipping away, reading their emails, going to different
chats, and then sometimes they don't come back.
So to improve that, we
looked at a streaming solution so that we
could keep the client engaged, and
that's when we introduced, um, App sync,
which Salmon touched on and Walter will be, um,
explaining. Getting that streaming going
as soon as Bedrock starts creating the
content, you get that scrolling effect,
almost near immediate response.
The second challenge we talked about was
this huge library of complex prompts. What are we
gonna do with them now?
We had a UI in front of it.
The model was, you know,
if this then that if you're doing this
post, choose this prompt,
and then thank goodness MCP came around
and that really opened up an opportunity to start
having a dynamic library of prompts
so the concept that we're looking at is
putting all your prompts into the MCP catalog.
Being able to
tell the server what you're wanting to do
and it'll choose the prompts on the back end
and you'll get a pretty deterministic
output in terms of if you put in
enough detail as to what each prompt does
it'll go through and start choosing the right
tools.
Salman did touch on, you know, MCP being
the enabler for building these deterministic agents,
and I think this, you know, this
phased approach that we've taken with content assist
is taking us further down the road to full
autonomy. We're not there yet, but it's
getting you further down the road.
When you first talking about started talking about LLMs
and
MCP it was a little bit, it was hard for me
to. Understand at
first because the whole concept of an LLM being able to think
like a human.
So I'm gonna share a simple analogy that I
um started through and
it's a little experiment like you can do in cloud.
AI if you want to to kind of understand
the connection between LLM's
tools and MCP.
Everybody knows as you start moving to agentic
is very goal oriented. You just wanna
explain what your problem is and you want the LLM
to solve it. So in this particular example
we wanna build an engaging social media marketing
post for
a particular topic.
So we start with giving it
a list of tools and Salman and
Dennis had talked about that.
So in this case we have brand guidelines,
content examples,
social media post trends,
and also some random tools a hammer, a lawn mower,
and of course an instant pot.
So we provided this list of tools to the LLM.
It knows what it wants to do, and we asked it which
tools would you choose.
So it actually goes through and tells me it's gonna take the guidelines,
examples, and the social media trends,
and it'll actually tell me
it threw out the hammer, lawn mower, and the instant pot.
So now we know which tools it's selected.
And then I'll ask it how are you gonna use these tools
without any instructions, and it'll actually
build me a step by step guide as to what it's
gonna be doing. I didn't have to instruct it at all
just based on its knowledge
and its thinking capability, it
told me step by step. I'm gonna start with the guidelines,
look at the examples,
understand the trends, draft the post. It gave
me a lot more details
and review, rewrite, and presented
back with reasoning.
So with that said.
You can see how this starts forming your
next generation agentic workflow if
you can start kicking off more.
Activities in the back end maybe you wanna
create it maybe you wanna start emailing it to
a distribution list maybe you wanna put it onto
SharePoint,
put it into a workflow you can start
creating these um
different steps
and the beauty of using MCP is as
you start adding more tools,
let's say I start building a library of
um. How our social media posts
have been performing and let's say I threw that into
a simple SharePoint with descriptions on each
post.
I could actually have a tool does a
standard rag approach,
pull the latest details, what's been performing well,
cats in the snow videos if that's trending well.
I wanna pull that in as my good
examples and I can start creating dynamic
examples in my content creation
process. So huge opportunities with MCP
and like I said.
Building it modularly allows you to drop it
in and
maybe some other groups will be using
those tools. LLM will decide and start exposing
them similar to the concierge approach
that Dennis said we're gonna have a lot of tools in there
and we really want the concierge to help us
understand which ones to use.
If you take the hotel example, if a new
restaurant pops up,
they sell pizza,
they're gonna offer, hey, you know, Rob, there's a pizza shop
there you wanna go there.
So we can just dynamically expose that
and the LLM like a concierge will
be able to um help help through
things. Problem
with coming on, um, a Thursday
session is there's so much new releases
on, um, at reinvent,
so we kinda updated some of our slides
for those that attended the, um,
uh, Swami session we talked about Agent Corp.
You probably think there's a lot of opportunities
in there in there for content assist,
and definitely there is.
There's semantic search to help find the right
tools,
um, policy and evaluations to make
sure that you're choosing these agents that
are working or doing a good job.
And episodic memories was the one that's
interesting. If something went,
you know, off the rails in one quarter, let's
say you created these cat videos that really flopped.
The episodic memories will allow us to when we
start creating things it'll remind us that hey you know
what, last year
you had a good idea it failed, don't go
there. So all those things that are coming
to Asian core is gonna be a huge I think as
we move forward with uh content assist.
So I talked about how all these things come together,
but there's a lot that happens in the back
end and Walter's gonna talk about the
technology and the architecture behind that.
And there's a lot of steps, but
I'll pass it off to Walter.
Thanks.
Thanks Dennis and Robert. That was, uh, for
that context. That was, that was great.
Um, so in this section, I'll, we'll do a deep dive
into how we use AWS App Sync to accelerate
our solution
and reduce latency.
We'll explore how real-time streaming transformed
our user experience, turning long
waits into interactive, transparent
progress updates.
And then we'll walk through the architecture and key
design decisions.
My name is Walter Kurzatz. I'm a senior
principal software engineer at SunLife.
I led the engineering efforts behind our
AppSync implementation,
working closely with our engineering teams to
design and deliver a solution
that met our robust enterprise
requirements.
Today, I'll show you how our architecture.
Leverages ASync's managed graphQL service,
private APIs, and real-time streaming
to support complex,
long-running workflows.
You'll see how we integrated AppSync with Amazon
Bedrock, Lambda, and our
model context protocol server to
orchestrate multi-step processes.
So yeah, later on, Rob will walk you through the demo
and we'll show you in our how our solution
streams streams the progress updates
in real time and instead of loading a
spinner and uncertainty, you'll
see updates as they actually occur.
The complexity of Gen AI workflows
and lack of scalable streaming infrastructure
were some of the hurdles that we had to overcome.
As we advanced our Gen AI initiatives,
we encountered several significant challenges
that shaped our approach,
and as our use cases became more complex,
the complexity of context increased
dramatically,
requiring substantially more time to
complete. As Rob
mentioned, our second challenge was user
experience. Our users are accustomed to
instant responses, and with
complex reasoning and longer wait times,
there was a real risk of users abandoning
their sessions.
So let's get started with the architecture overview,
and then I'll move into a demonstration so
you can see AppSync streaming in action.
So in this slide,
I'll walk you through the key components and technologies
of our AppSync solution.
Our UI was written in React
JS and we are leveraging the
Apollo,
uh, TypeScript client libraries
to manage our graphQL subscriptions,
queries, and mutations.
Our net our networking and and hosting,
we're we're leveraging OpenShift and
Kubernetes for container and orchestration
management. In there we've
implemented a secure gateway to access our
lambda functions.
We've implemented Engine X to
act as our reverse proxy to manage
our web socket connections.
And then finally we have our MCP server
implemented as a container as well.
We also are leveraging AWS
identity and access management.
We have implemented a, uh, invoke
role to allow us to access App
syncs
within our network account.
And we are using STS to
actually do an assumed role in that network
account which allows us to get temporary
credentials to access the app sync
itself. AWS
Resource access manager,
as Solomon alluded to, we,
we implemented that to enable
cross-account resource sharing
for ASync. Our A sync is implemented in
two places our network or foundation
account, also in our private, uh,
workload account.
And of course AWS OPSync itself,
it's a fully managed graphQL service
and for our solution we're leveraging it
for the real-time streaming.
AWS lambda,
our serverless compute, we're leveraging
it, um.
To, to implement our, our, our backend
approach, our backend strategy, so we have
3 lambda functions. We have our API
lambda,
which is we're using to do our assume role
in our network account.
Uh, we're using
a data source lambda, which acts
as an intermediary processing our
graphQL requests.
And then finally we have our lambda
orchestrator, which is really putting it all together,
connecting to
SNS connecting to Bedrock, connecting
to AppSync, and of course it is also our
MCP host and client.
We have that we're using SNS for secured
pub and sub notification. So in this case,
our data source lambda is
publishing to SNS and our
lambda orchestrator
is subscribing to that.
We're leveraging AWS Bedrock
for the LLM integration as well as the
streaming API which we're using
to actually write back to sync our
mutations.
And then finally our model context protocol,
which provide, which we're using to host
our uh system prompts
as well as our content scoring tools.
So let's walk through step one.
So in step one, the user, the UI
sends a request through our secured gateway
to the back end lambda to obtain temporary
credentials.
These credentials allow our UI to send
requests to the shared app sync endpoint
in our network account.
The lambda function uses the AWSSTS
to assume an IAM role
in the network account. The network account's
IAM role then trusts this,
the lambda's execution role,
and grants the permissions to invoke sync.
Just as a note here,
um, we are using SIGV4
in the headers. This is required for APSync.
AppSync uses this to authorize
and authenticate.
Um, at the time that we created this
solution,
there was no other mechanism for authentication
authorization, so we were left with
using the SIGV4 headers.
So when RUI connects to the sync,
especially for real-time subscriptions via WebSocket,
it must sign the initial handshake shake
using SIGV 4 headers, and this signature
proves the request is authorized
using the temporary credentials obtained via
the lambda
and cross-count role assumption.
The UI uses the Apollo library
and step 2 uses the Apollo library to connect
to AppSync and subscribe to events.
It prepares the web socket connection signed
with the SIGV4 headers,
and that is passed as a query parameter
in the webSocket URL.
The web socket connection is established through
our Engine X reverse proxy.
The reverse the reverse proxy
accepts our web socket upgrade request and
then forwards the web socket connection to
the app sync endpoint in our network account.
The app sync network
app sync in a network account then validates
the SIGV4 signature,
the temporary credentials, and forwards the request
to our private app sync instance.
AppSync establishes the the subscription
and enables the streaming of the real-time
data to the client via the web socket
connection.
And then finally,
just a little note here, subscription and graphQL
is a way for the client to receive real-time
updates from the server whenever certain events
or data changes occur.
So instead of repeatedly polling for a specific
event or a data stream
and gets notified instantly when
something happens.
So in AWS
apps in AWS app sync graphQL subscriptions
are defined in your schema and
typically use
defined in your schema typically use a non-data source
which allows you to execute custom logic
or transformations without connecting to a
back end.
In a multi-account
in a multi-account setup.
The subscription requests are securely
forwarded to a private app sync
instance which processes events
and streams real-time updates back to the
client over web sockets.
This approach enables instant event-driven
feedback while keeping the backend
resources protected.
And step
step 2, do you oops, sorry.
OK.
And step 2,
The UI uses the Apollo library
to connect to AppSync and subscribe
to the events. It prepares the web socket connection.
Uh, sorry.
I think it was one of my slides got messed up here.
I'll just skip to this next section here, so the user
submits the graphQL query through
the established web socket connection.
The request is routed through Engine X
reverse proxy, and then forwards the
request to the web socket.
Topsync
sync in the network account receives
oh man.
Oh yeah, OK.
The app sync of the network account then receives the
query, validates the SIGV4 signature
and temporary credentials, and routes the
request to the appropriate API and resolver.
In this case, the resolver is get
content response.
The resolver
transforms the graphQL query into
a payload for the data source
lambda, and then invokes the lambda
itself.
The DS lambda, the data source lambda.
Receives the payload,
processes it, and publishes it to the SNS
topic fire and forget.
And finally, the LLM orchestrator
lambda is is is is subscribed
to that topic, and when triggered,
it receives the payload and invokes the
bedrock LLM streaming API.
And when triggered,
And and the orchestrator lander then streams the
tokens from the bedrock,
from bedrock, buffering them and sending the
updates back to AppSync as they are
generated.
So how does this happen?
The mutation send message is defined
in the A sync schema
and is mapped to to use
a resolver,
which is again configured as a non-data
source. The resolver acts
as a correlation ID mechanism to
ensure that the right client receives the mutation
before posting the response back to the
web socket connection.
And finally, how does MCP fit into
our solution?
The user requests the social media
content providing basic context.
LLM then the LLM connects
to the MCP server via server
sent event transport.
The server announces what's available,
what prompts are available, what tools are available.
The lambda orchestrator then requests
a system prompt which instructs the LLM
to execute the scoring tool from a
list of available tools after
the content has actually been generated.
The LLM, the LLM then generates
the social media content based on the system
prompt,
and finally the LLM invokes the MCP
scoring tool as instructed by the
system prompt.
The lambda orchestrator streams the scoring
results back to the UI.
OK, so I think this next step we'll just
walk through a bit of a demo,
seeing all this in action.
All right, thanks Walter. So
now you've seen the
crazy technical portion in the back and I'm gonna show you the,
the easy stuff that I look at the front end.
So for this demo
we talked about our fictional,
uh, cat videography company that offers premium
cat photo and video creation service.
We come to your cat. You don't have to bring the cat to us.
So in this particular promotion we're launching
a new winter holiday photo pack for clients
with multiple cats, 15%
off for each additional cat.
It's a great gift idea for a cat loving,
for that cat loving friend that's so hard to buy for.
So this is content assist
and I'm gonna try this thing.
The right hand screen is actually the one
that's gonna be showing the app sync streaming and
the left hand side is the uh
the legacy version that we had working.
So as you can see we've chosen
the menus, social media, generate
content we're targeting the US customers
as well as we wanna do let's
say Instagram,
kick it off,
see the dancing dots and you'll see the app sync
version it starts streaming as soon as.
You send it and then Bedrock starts creating
the content and it starts generating
it. You'll see the other side start catching up
soon. And you'll see it
does a post, it does the reasoning,
and it's gonna keep going because in the
uh the new version we've actually
have the scoring engine
inside the MCP so it's actually decided to
score the content at the end
so you'll see it gives a whole category score,
brand alignment, grammar, and these are all
different scoring mechanisms
that you can put in place depending on what kind
of content you're looking for.
So that's really.
Totally customizable depending on the content. If
you're writing, let's say technical content,
you may wanna score differently in terms of, you know,
technical terms complexity
so it's totally customizable like I
said before it all comes down to
the prompts and how you design them for your
specific business units.
Uh, some of these, you know, some of these lessons learned
from, you know,
going through consciousness. I know Walter.
I come to you with a lot of
crazy ideas and you seem to
kind of bring the team together to actually solution
them. Like if you were to look at
the lessons learned, what would you say was the
biggest challenge
that you had to deal with?
So, well, I've, I've put a few bullet points in here,
but I would say leveraging ASync,
uh, sort of connection pooling was a
was a big deal for us uh initially
we started using AppSync.
It didn't really perform the way we thought it should,
but then we realized it was really our implementation
of it and how we were using it, so
making those connections every single time, doing the
handshakes
where, you know, something that you had to leverage
just a a pool for connection pools
for that. So without doing that, doing all of that
work up each and every time, that can
be time consuming
and always be open to new technologies like I
talked about before, you know, we started,
you know, deploying on.
Just doing our content creation within
our sunlight Fast tool then we
built a solution
deployed in a container. Now we're looking at gent
core and
who knows what's going to release next week. It seems to be
a new release from AWS every, every
week, so build it modularly
so you can move it around wherever you want. I think
that's kind of one of the biggest lessons learned build something
that's cohesive, solid that you can
deploy right?
But as you can see it was a huge.
You know, architecture diagram, a lot of folks
have to work on it we kind of pushed the limits on a lot of these
different services and scenarios,
so as you can see.
These are a few folks that uh
were key contributors in terms of designing
the solution.
Every part of those boxes, and when you show me that architecture
box actually, Walter,
as we went through the project meetings, I can kind of look at
associating the names to each of these boxes, but
when it all came together and actually
gave that streaming demo, that was, um, that was
pretty amazing.
It's free. So
thank you everybody. I know thank you for staying for
the the last session. We're standing between you
and um
and the party, but we're gonna be around.
I know we had a lot of content to cover.
We'll be around if you have any questions on, you know,
whether it's MCP, A sync, content
creation,
uh, we'll be here.
Uh, please complete the survey in the mobile app.
Don't leave any stars on the table. It's your last session. You
can give us 5,
but, um, and enjoy, enjoy the party
tonight. Hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you.